I'm studying these problems deeply I'm
diving to the wrists into the the
darkest parts of America and to the
lightest parts and I want to you know
show people and teach people their own
there because these natives determine
what we can do and there is an air that
exists who does haven't read it they
just don't know about it because our
schools were bad and stuff
they haven't tell them to level and they
haven't taught them that great
democratic inheritance that we have you
know America and in the world but like
this place is awesome
ok America is so great it's so great
it's also really [ __ ] up and then
[ __ ] up for a long time and only by
loving us so much can you really deal
with those things and and but I believe
that all the materials we need are there
we have the internet we have the people
we have the the need we have all these
ingredients we just need these catalysts
start things moving and I want to help
be that catalyst oh what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Alan
Sakia we are on-site at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
MIT in the beautiful Cambridge
Massachusetts we are now going to be
talking about the Great American Novel
we have Aidan Fitzsimmons joining us on
the show hello hello Alan thank you so
much for coming on really appreciate it
thanks for having me
I'm super-pumped eight and I have been
talking so much prior to this interview
he's a philosopher writer and
synthesizer focused on the Great
American Novel which puts together all
the most important ideas from American
poetry philosophy literature history and
thought and you can check out Aidan's
links below
Aidan let's start things off with our
question what is your current take on
the state of our world asymmetrical and
hollowed-out so by what I mean by that
is history history doesn't progress like
in perfectly right like the the mean of
every dice roll isn't doesn't happen
every time so there's all these
professions all these things get stuck
humans are such like a fallen you know
species like there's something both
perfect or striving and imperfect
and so our world the last I'd say since
the 60s when was the last time we saw
sort of like a true like flood of
consciousness of people certainly aware
of the structures around them that made
them who they are and started wanting to
like you know expand beyond them and
create new structures they sort of lost
right they lost RFK was shot Nixon MLK
was shot Nixon won Reagan won Clinton
won Bush won like these these it's been
the same story for the past year it's
the victory of capital it's you know the
Cold War both sides leaned into their
own and it leaned into themselves
leading to their ego like you know I
mean so Congress and gets a character of
itself and capitalism and Regan in
response to the USA because the
character itself and we've been still
living in that paradigm that they that
the baby boomers sold out and created we
think of the baby boomers as the sixties
like hippies but that was like a small
percentage of them most of them sold off
from beginning and the rest sold out as
time went on and the you know Gen X and
the at least the first half of the
Millennials have sort of you know
inherited that world appeared on there's
many changed no one's no one's escaped
we've been seeing less and less sort of
fewer or a few and fewer of these like
you know people who push us outside and
so what we have now is this culture that
has sort of never known anything but
this sort of consumerism this sort of
hollow this idea that at the end of
history this idea that this idea that we
live in a world that's done with history
history was war too and those easily
their and their devised well things I
mean in my use history class in my
public school like we never got past
Watergate then we didn't learn I think
past them like you week we just don't
know the history of the world that's
created us that we're born into we come
into totally oblivious and because of
like our affluence which is hollowing
out right like like money versus like
creation is a very different thing right
like we've been able to sort of sit back
on ourselves for a while and like let it
nourish sort of ossify things halt on
the inside because we can and we don't
have to we don't have the adversities
not immediate obvious to us so we can
kind of you know push it off the way the
baby boomers taught us to do
and it's ignore at all and I think it's
getting the rot is starting to show and
you know things like things like Trump
like and things like just all the
conflicts are in the world the way that
social media is being used you can tell
that like the very fact that like the
Internet's happens so full communication
you know it's almost possible and
instead of like achieving you know
collective excellence together all of
our like weaknesses are being amplified
it just shows that I guess so another
reason I say hallo is because our
technology as I've stripped our morality
long live the king has a quote I like
that but it's just like a general
thought people had for a long time you
know especially post war to post like
military district complex money post the
rationalization of the University and
you know all these things we have a
world where people we have a world
created by the great minds and the great
inventions the great thoughts of
everything's came before us but then we
their inheritors who inherit this big
you know cyborg we're all operating you
know like together we differ read the
drive like we wait for the drivers many
well we haven't learned from the great
people from our past we do we haven't
had to and haven't realized that we have
to so I think we're hollow and I'll
sling race not cool in the sense that
like right now capitals kind of digging
in right like capital like like money
and power there's been this big sift for
a while like here's the elephant sharp
here's the elephant chart people feeling
different parts of the elephant saying
that they're seeing different things no
no the elephant chart is on a chart of
world economic growth in the last like
50 years right and like percent of girls
so so it's an imagined elephant right so
like um and then it's like it's like big
big hump and then a big dip for the
trunk in them it didn't hit the trunk so
like people and like you know it
developed I was like India and China is
this big big back of the trunk like
these huge growth last 50 years and then
the very the trunk that the the tip the
tail is like the own global like one
percent point one percent but then the
dip the big dip like near zero said like
oh people whose lives like haven't gone
like in a relative sense better since
like the like 70s 80s is like the former
like NATO middle class
essentially we're just been hauled out
when we're seeing else until you know
fax him that now
and so capitals and so people are
starting to realize but also money
empower have so many you know avenues
which to power over us the culture
industry like the way they can set all
of our narratives make a sort of blind
to the things that need to be done so
right we're in SE now is all since
asymmetrical digging in Fox News is
another example to preserve power when
its basis is being hollowed out by the
day sim with our big down numbers like
that when we create measures right for
an economy when was we create standards
and measures and tests we're going to
start doing whatever we can to pass that
test whether or not we retain the actual
virtues and goals that were there to
begin with so let's make the Dower like
the the Walshy numbers like the measure
of the economy as a whole we star like
leaning into that way and trying to pass
tests by any means necessary
without maybe showing the same
underlying values that once made that
test valuable so that was a long ramble
but you can tell that Aidan is a
synthesizer
yeah I definitely thinking broad strokes
and nice to bracket I'm just you know I
don't want to like lay a hundred percent
claim to anything I say in a sense like
shoulders of giants
I'll say myself young we all know that
totally know that and you gave so many
excellent examples throughout history
through the use of technology I loved
the even on the global scale the idea of
this elephant and that's a really good
way of displaying people that have been
just taken out of what is was just a
couple dollar a day of income to couple
of tens of dollars if not even $100 a
day of income compared to people that
you you used to make $100 a day income
that have stayed in $100 a day income
yes and then the very end of the tale of
the trunk which is just subscriber
listening sort of forces companies yeah
that's that's that's that's a really
good one and also just your your overall
idea of the the code that society has
been
pushing forth since really the
Industrial Revolution has been about
this number of the economy and the
number of making civilization better
which we have in many ways eradicated a
lot of disease and issues increased
longevity increase the quality of living
with a lot of access to information
technology in this type of stuffs great
simultaneously our spiritual
actualization and transcendence and
guide towards the unity and cohesion and
planetary harmony with nature and our
ecosystem that we reside in has taken a
backseat to the numbers of GDP and how
the warming like I mean or the kind of
changes what do you know that is an
example of the effects of that yes you
can tell aaden's obviously just on
absolute fire with with this and I'm
really glad I'm really glad that that
was the you know that was a really
powerful state of the world another way
to put it as you initially said is that
what happened to MLK what happened to
JFK what happened to Lenin what happened
to a lot of these leaders around the
world that wanted a deeper drive towards
peace and harmony and unfortunately
there seemed to be potentially forces
that work together to make sure that
that did not come to be yes and why has
it been that that that Libya Iraq and
Afghanistan were potentially some of the
targets for centralized banking to be
implemented interesting yeah and why our
Iran and North Korea some of the last
ones and why are they targets as well
now and what does cryptocurrency and
blockchain technology mean for all of
this and and there's there's a lot more
to unpack with you and I'm sure you have
perspectives on all of what I just said
and we could probably talk for like ever
on all of this
and let's go let's do it jump because
let's jump there's still so much to talk
about let's jump in the movie I would
you bet yeah you're good you're silly
you're still in frame so let's jump into
the journey so born near Providence and
Rhode Island in the United States and
northeast corner and you as a kid you
didn't travel too much but you somehow
managed to get hooked into being some
good enough of a student to end up
getting into Harvard
yes so teach us about you growing up as
a kid and how that even happened okay
grandpa's kid I grew up in Swansea
Massachusetts which is right over the
border from Providence this whole crazy
colonial history as to why Swansea is
part of Massachusetts which shouldn't
page in perfect Island well in boom
Plymouth Colony that doesn't exist
anymore
but I love my hometown very much and I
love that the water like the
Narragansett Bay is definitely like in
in me so I'm like my streets of Boston
but I'm also Rhode Island and I have a
little sister
a little sister of two parents my mom is
very like social bubbly and like just a
saint and like a go-getter and like she
a very good person she helps like
English second language and and
first-generation low-income kids get
acclimated to UMass Dartmouth the
University of Massachusetts in the south
when a new bedford and Fall River the
city of x2.is and they're pretty like
they're pretty poor community so we
Willie that's like a huge population of
humanness Dartmouth and then my dad is
like a historian
he teaches like occasionally at Rhode
Island school design like a vietnam war
films class and stuff but he was like
the sort of stay-at-home dad growing up
and so and he and he and he and he's
like easy really and he's really
brilliant so him being my dad growing up
definitely helped make me who I am
same with my sister I hear she my sister
is much more like him I'm like my mom
but they raised me and when I was little
I'd say I'm gonna go to Hartford like I
heard it's a pretty good school you know
like because I was you know that full of
myself and then believed in my own
intelligence that much and then I was
like middle school then I skipped a
grade
and then like and then so then I went to
middle school I sort of forgot about
that left behind child sort of like
figure out how to be a person how to
like socialize how to like it's gonna be
great definitely big an impact on me so
I'd like socialize with and in this
small public school where I have one to
know each other for you know their whole
lives and the same grade together and so
that definitely if me and then I was in
theater I was an actor for a longest
time so I definitely saw like an actor
in my blood like acting's have formed my
life
in a lot of ways I think acting is very
important way important aspect of being
in general of being a person I think in
everything is acting and not in a false
way but in a true way everything is
acting and then and then I and then like
by the time I was its sophomore summer
of high school I was like so I get like
kind of just have enough time my parents
and have enough time like in my like
life in general and I came out that
somewhere with this burning dream that I
was gonna prove myself I was gonna go to
Harvard I was gonna get you know I in my
high school like the local community
college was sort of like the standard
slash the height and so it wasn't like
it wasn't like a plausible thing though
it wasn't like tossed around it wasn't
like talked about they weren't the
guidance counselor's who know anything
about anything so I just heard it myself
I just sorta do it myself and I was
really determined and I really thought I
could do it and I was and I figured like
I might as well you know try my very
hardest and believe that I can that's
the best chance I have that I'd have you
know then if I fail it's like let's try
my best and so I applied Harvard early
action I got in and it was like the best
day of my life
like yeah I mean like wow it's crazy
I'm still very great before I still walk
around like so grateful I don't take
anything for granted with the things
that you did in the from software your
senior year
of high school you think you could take
it in besides like doing like ice
creatures and you know being like
president drama company and and doing
like a show choir and do all this
historical volunteering at the local a
few local museums and then like in Fall
River and it's also a there's also like
a colonial Museum in my own town that I
worked for and it was my eyesight it was
mass as it got me in though I mean my
grades were all you know get my mi st
Center tests and all blah blah blah like
all the scores were perfect and stuff
but you know they didn't need another
leg of that but but but my essays were
unique my essays where I why I got it
I'm a hard person I have to my files or
anything but my assets were really good
and that was why I got and what did you
write about so from my comment app essay
they're both Harvick's Harper's reaction
it was like one for one but come at us
they was like very like well-written
dramatic it was about theater and
socialization and my like my life and it
was more it was more tragic and like but
also hopeful and powerful and like well
over in and about like me becoming a
person and then like Harvard supplement
was a satire about the iron knight who
was me on his quest to you know to to
like be better than all the like there's
like this my feels like silver and
Golden Knights you know like with a
[ __ ] shining their armor and it was in
this quest to go to the king the Dean of
Admissions and ask him it convinced him
to allow me to marry his daughter the
princess Harvard and I sort of just it's
very funny a so as I really like funny
piece I even made incest joke about the
Dean of Admissions because his name was
Dean William Fitzsimmons and so I have
one uh Sam than him but I made like a
test joke but I'm it at a Yale joke too
and I'm just one good funny and and then
I end with Attila sincere speech like
I'm like purposefully and truthfully
like sincere and naive speech sort of
like yeah I know like there's all these
awesome knights they're like all Kingdom
jesters and [ __ ] and like they're great
but I and like I've talked about myself
and just I can't you know I can't like
swear any of these things to you all I
can say is that a like trying to win
your princess trying to trying to make
myself better too
be worth this Harvard has made me better
this journey this dream had in the
stream that I worked so hard for has
made me better so I think you know Irish
thank you for you know don't get in like
I mean I can't marry her like I thank
you for that and be like I just I can't
even begin to imagine the amazing things
that we could do together
she and I it was just very sincere and
like youthful and heartfelt plus the the
the joke about the Dean and incest
probably like golly got the reading was
probably hot bill get in here like sniff
I'll get my name looked a little more
remembered so yeah okay cool that's good
that's good on you for writing a very
strong essay and what was it called in
the addition to their save thionite or
the yeah but the iron Knights called a
what is it called in addition to the
essay the Common App essay oh it's the
Harvard supplement is the harvest woman
yes okay write whatever you want
probably cool yeah yeah so the
supplement si plus all the the
leadership and the extracurriculars and
the and the excellent grades and test
scores okay cool cool
so then alright so you have this
profound moment of the oh my gosh I'm in
Harvard holy cow alright what is it like
landing here in 2016 in the Harvard of
zoo so I am one thing I was very you
know it's surreal excited and grateful
like I was meeting us people making
friends but on the other hand I was
pretty disillusioned a very fast
Harvard well being the best places on
earth was also because it's not using
its power very well it's it too is
hollowed it to is like sort of I'm not a
large lot a lot of larger problem the
society and even the problems you can
see it happening around you you can
imagine like okay fifty percent of my
classmates are going into like
consulting in finance and gonna have
Wi-Fi power structures and they're not
in like and there they got here because
these various essential lottery factors
of like these parents this neighborhood
this school system this upper-middle
class way of like life and moving
through a system that I guess if you
imagine like if everyone every year is
like this across all the other cost
Princeton Chicago Stanford if everyone's
like this
what we're gonna do like has ever been
like this for the past 15 years because
a lot of things about the world today
would make a lot of sense if like if the
leaders there will have been like all
like this because they're all just like
they're smart in a system following way
there's they're good at following the
obvious cheese you know whereas like
like like like meat show would have torn
his hair out you know like like the more
important and told us to like break out
of the systems your interest transcend
to recombine to to subvert and no one's
do it I just expected to get there and
do be surrounded by like way like
brilliant people in different ways
who would all teach me something new and
we don't get excited talking till the
wee hours and we'd synthesize we trying
to save the world together and then like
would that was really happening and then
Trump got elected and I was I mean
everyone was shot everyone was had some
personal reaction to it but people
people moved on with life as usual
really fast and I couldn't I couldn't
the Trump elected is display it's so
much deeper than just a political
problem or just like a this problem or
that problem it's it's the Komen it's
like it's all of the problems that we
haven't dealt with as a culture and as a
civilization as a world as a country as
a spq as individuals forever forever
we've lived that all the things we've
pushed off are still here and we still
haven't done with them Hisss the history
that makes us is still unfinished it's
still flawed this there's there are sins
in us as well as successes and we
haven't dealt with all of them and we
can you know we have all the people we
have all the every idea that exists is
part of the image kind of whole so we
just have to take more of those holes in
to fix the other parts there's no you
know there's no discontinuity so we just
have to dig and try harder there's like
a culture and as people we just aren't
and so I took deep cultural problem and
I decided I wanted to go crazy because I
felt like people were crazy enough and I
want to be crazier so I quick on the way
there okay okay yes because I must say
that you paint this beautiful visual of
what potentially is old code propagating
on cow yes without new code intervention
and so when we get too deep into these
measurements that we were initially
talking about at the beginning yeah of
GDP and the Dow and you go into the same
follow the cheese the same way this
hardened ruts these contours yes when
when the new code doesn't have space to
breathe to be deployed into the world
due to the economic machinery that's
constantly going that it requires some
sort of a crazy code deployment kind of
like what we saw with whatever satoshi
nakamoto and blockchain technology is in
order for kind of the world in a sense
to start getting flipped over on its
head and so for the new code to actually
get deployed and I think that we need to
give more breathing space for a new code
to come in to be able to tackle some of
these problems and so you're Villa
straited if this is right potentially
Europe Asia the United States all these
different places in the world these Ivy
League academic institutions if the
contours are that way towards the cheese
were in a sense we're carving the
problem for ourselves as I just clear
deeper and yes it keeps going yeah it's
just well said thank you thank you yeah
okay so then Trump and you're like and
you're like wow we need to tackle this
and you actually decided to tackle part
of this yeah yourself through a story
yeah the culture yeah yeah so I so I
read on the road by Jack Kerouac
he was like Beat Generation they drove
around the country on adventures they
knew time like we know time jack we know
time this day of like as much much miss
per second like living life like a very
freeing reading that book was like a
very freeing experience it's got plenty
of flaws and it's not my favorite book
ever but it's one of them and it
inspired me to like they also hitchhiked
a little bit in the book they mostly
drove way back in the 40s 50s 60s and
70s it was very normal to hitchhike it
was like Joe come home and hitchhike it
was a respectable man with a new piece
we have cars you know I'm already going
somewhere yeah come along with neighbour
come on friend whereas in this sort of
victory of capital scenario that I
described earlier this like post Mixon
post radiant especially this this fear
that's digging in this ego sort of
conservative impulse this sort of this
closedness this this anti liberalism
this anti openness sort of impulse to
live in your own you know gated
community and be afraid of what's on TV
that narrative went over the idea of
like hitchhikers murder and the person
killing hitchhikers murderer so
everyone's murder and we can't trust one
another and I think that's very related
to our problems like politically today
the idea that we just like our
countrymen like my brother in the in
Georgia isn't my brother he's something
because he's the other to be afraid of
and that's stupid where everyone's
people you know everyone's people and
people are good you know ninety nine
percent and we can't let like the one
percent ruin that for us you know and so
I wanted to prove that there was still
trust and still community and still
things to be learned adventure to be had
and so I decided to hitchhike around
America the summer between freshmen and
sophomore year and I did I guy you know
I saved us some money we're tied Rideau
bar for May and half of June and then
end of June I set up my backpack and I
did a whole eight thousand mile you know
loop-de-loop around America s all these
national parks all these cities these
the cultural areas talked to you know
180 drivers plus another couple hundred
people on the streets of cities and and
couch-surf people hosts and things like
that and I just like I just had such
profound effects on me it changed me
forever I mean I'll never I'll never be
the same it I'm gonna go again this
summer to I mean I I can't resist
anymore I get to an see I got a you know
I gotta go this the roads like right
there like that same road touches San
Francisco so it's like it's right there
so yeah adventure in America and since
then I've been you know trying to write
a novel about it about the journey using
that journey and probably the dream to
this summer as like the applause the
basis for this adventure story but use
it as an excuse to sort of paint this
mosaic of ideas and arguments in
essences from America like American
thought American history American flow
the best American philosophers the great
American novels the greatest American
poetry the ideas that made America
America not only the ideas that have
existed but ideas have been gestured
towards you know the things that have
been implied from day one like I'm not
created equal right we've been always
trying to get to there we believe it you
know there's all these ideals and
there's all these problems to these deep
deep bad things to to dig through to but
we have to we have to dig all the way
through them we have to take them all in
us we um Walt Whitman who's like the
most American person he's the he's
American culture he's the American
prophet he's he's expansive he in his
call for what the the greatest poet will
be which is like a himself but also come
to the future he's like future followers
talks about how America is like the
greatness of poems and it draws from
every language and land it draws all
these they it's like the great
synthesizer you know it's a great open
vessel the great open synthetic thing
full honesty full to take in your time
like it's taking like that like the
zeitgeist essentially as it as a as like
vast ocean tides and I do too to be your
time to be the voice that you're - that
comes through you after your time goes
into you I guess I'm rambling a little
bit you're rushing it doing so well and
the way that you talk again is just so
evident of a really strong synthesizer
so what happens when you end up going
and 180 different hitchhike drivers that
you rode with hundreds of people from
different cities official to 250 rides
now yeah yeah you're about to go on
potentially more definitely a lot of the
greatest American novelists and poets
also
synthesis synthesizing all of this
together thinkers and it kind of
produces you yeah and so this is it
makes a lot of sense hearing you speak
the way you do because you know more
hollowed out
world that's kind of following the same
contours towards the cheese we're
missing people yes like you and and I
and I hope that the same way that we
view people like Alex Kate Chen that
introduced us that that that we view
people like you and him and myself as
going in a way that is carving out a
different contour yeah and that that
different contour can lead other young
people to follow their own yes novel car
absolutely yeah my path my path is my
path is to try to open many paths as
possible for others that's definite what
I want to do with my book the title the
title is is beaten path be8 ein ' path
so if the president it's me it's
happening it's the synthesis of all
those passed pass in the bibliography of
the book which will itself be a consist
of America you know that as an idea of
course income an incomplete connect us
but but a good starting point in the
West for for anyone with this one book
to sort of start their own journey
through American thought to be able to
follow to read Emerson or to read Tony
Morrison to bounce off my journey my
path and that Babar face beaten paths
right like tean past tense plural paths
it so is this sort of you know the way
the present combines at a point from
yeah yeah
so Aidan also decided that after he
decides to take on this massive journey
across the the United States that he
also is doing a lot of articles and
poems and getting involved in in some
writing on campus and and you're now to
the point where you're just kind of like
well maybe I need to compound my
intelligence with absolute freedom yes
and so this is one of the things that I
think is difficult for for young people
to make decisions on as well as the
contour is already you know
you've s yourself three years of that
path yes and so for you to be able to
say like is is is me in my most awakened
state and you said you know in the 60s
we had potentially one of the greatest
eruptions of awakening and consciousness
that kind of again just fell back into
the economic machine that could it
potentially be that young people after
one year two years three years of school
need to just kind of sometimes if
they're really wanting to compound their
intelligence outside of that academic
institution system need to pull the plug
and you're kind of considering that as
potentially you know what you need to do
to write the great American yes yeah I
I've been to one with this for a year
now if I want one take time off because
I'm so dedicated as part I I've bought
ferociously like all these books right I
have a hundred like like I have so many
books that are sitting there waiting to
be read that I'm very excited to read
that fit into this long web this web of
time that is the is like American ideas
right that I that the more I read the
more that picture could stuff out the
more each indicates one another the more
these central dialyze essential themes
develop themselves I can see who
responds to who I can see how Jean
Toomer response to Cory McCarthy I can
see where Whitman and Emerson diverge
and what that means for their followers
after you I mean like and it's its
intellectual I'm it makes me want to
read all the time like my free time is
reading but it's for me what I want to
read rather than my classes and I've
done well in my past two years to make
all my classes more majority my classes
fit in with this project but at this
point next I had to write a thesis for
social studies which is my major which I
don't feel ready to do I'd rather focus
entirely on this and get this project
done first and really go all in on it
rather than split myself up and I just
feel at this point that being in school
is gonna be back I don't want it you
know just as far as time pressure
systems gonna talk to distractions
writing and reading for a class rather
than for me I want to be able to make my
novel a full-time job that I wake up in
the morning read write read write and
hitchhike in the for vacations
and to be in that mindset again because
that's a very different mindset then
school mindset just being on the road
like because your environment is so
different it makes your mind very
different and it's way more
philosophical I can't wait to get back
to that state of mind and at this point
I just think that self education will do
better for me then being educated by
Harvard especially I'm gonna like even
though more like full financial aid like
paying to be there like someone's paying
me to be there like why would I pay to
be there when I could learn faster and
better on my own for now and then come
back sort of extend my Harvard time a
little bit longer you know be able to
like visit I'll be able to meet more
Harvard students and I make a lot of
friends for you I make a lot of friends
because I you know I talk people from
trees and stuff and I like one around I
talk to strangers and today I talked up
like five strangers it was sunny out you
know I was like wandering anyway so
being at Harvard physically for more
years like more friends definitely
viable to me also be able to like audit
classes I could just show up to lectures
and learn for me learning is I guess I
guess learning for me is much more about
learning than it is about the degree
even though I'll get the degree which is
why I know I'll be fun I'm not gonna
like die of starvation
you know like I'd rather this is what
matters to me is this this project and
it feels urgent I already feel because I
started this whole idea in like
essentially like early 2017 I feel
guilty that it wasn't ready for 2020 you
know I mean like I feel like responsible
and I feel like if if I if I had if I
had been more dedicated maybe I could
have done it faster and at this point I
definitely haven't done at least before
the 2022 midterms yeah oh man yeah so
this is one of the things that we were
chatting about a little beforehand
off-camera to is that this requires a
good amount of calculus of math yes of
analyzing trajectory of life outcome and
for all of those that are watching that
either are in school themselves or that
have family members or friends that are
in school that are contemplating this
this is actually very important question
to ask where do you map your life
trajectory if you are to just full-time
do what you
every single moment of every day if you
are as passionate as Eden is or if you
just have some some some TrueNorth that
you really need to follow in this exact
moment you with the mind that is you
know 16 18 20 years old is just
compounding the knowledge that you gain
at 16 18 or 20 s versus if you wait
until you're 22 or 24 26 to go towards
that true north
so going at it or as early as possible
so critical so this is a very important
thing to do math and calculus on this
life trajectory but I'm really happy
that you're voicing this because it's
such a crucial topic for other people to
to think about and do you have
conversations about yeah I'm just
grateful that you are yeah you have a
true north that you can pursue with this
the fact that you have that in your 20
20 20 and your 20 and you have a true
north that you can pursue like that at
least for now once you finish it you
move on in patience is a very important
thing because Oshana continues
synthesizing information and it's just
gonna keep getting better and better and
better but then yes there does need to
be some sort of a publication sometimes
yeah well I won't force it out I left
look I love you our date itself
yeah that's extremely important - yeah
I'd rather got the Great American Novel
right and timeless timeless sense right
correct so it might take a little bit
longer than just waiting a year until
2020 but just also that you know you
mentioned these funny things that you
know that you you are very eccentric in
your behaviors you know you likely climb
more trees than I do but I definitely
climb at least a tree a month or two
hell yeah and that's so amazing it's so
important to do that and I got cuts and
stuff
yeah from Shree climbing it gives
there's so many important things that
come with that not only does it feel
like it's where we come from but also
it's it's just a beautiful thing to be
eccentric could be hanging out on the
tree and just looking people watching
slash talking to people she's very fun
thing I want to hit on some of your
thoughts around what's happening with
our ability to engage in inspire
generations II yeah
so we have like you mentioned at the
beginning that what's going on with
Millennials why has there been such a
again just following a very similar path
into the economy rather than this uproar
and this ability to and put deploy the
new code in Gen Z on the other hand is a
lot younger they've had technology
growing up their whole lives they're
kind of technology experts in a sense of
knowing what's happening at the cutting
edge of the moment that it's happening
in what sense - in a fluid says but
especially in smartphone technology
versus potentially one that like you
know Gen Z doesn't really I guess
understand what's happening at the edge
of synthetic biology let me now say so
so that it's kind of a different edge in
a sense but for them to be able to rally
and engage and move forward on a subject
and you I love your your thought here
with something that galvanized stem like
this idea of water yes yes for teach us
about this okay so yeah I think gen Z is
important I think I think I think I mean
of course every generation is important
but I think because of the deterministic
way though the world is Generation Z
because because media is an extension of
our humanity right and because the way
we can act is very much constrained
determined by the words and narratives
that we have to act upon the fact that
uh we weren't raised on capital a
capital owned T television you know I
mean our narrative and the fact that yes
we had the same shitty education as
generation we're the same shitty
education that the past third iteration
have had except probably even worse
because we haven't like you know the
more the world changes than what we keep
things the same the farther apart sort
of they get we do have the internet we
had Wikipedia we had the Wild West
Internet we had like downloading illegal
movies because we could you know I mean
so I think then we have a very specific
sort of way that like knowledge is ours
in a way that uh it wasn't before and I
think that um generation see also very
realistically like because of the future
matters in calculus even of course we
would just kind the future but it's
still we also do counted like the idea
that there's like high super high rates
of like anxiety depression stuff among
the younger generation
yes it's part social-media yes that's
part adhesion system but it's also part
like a realistic response to like the
shitstorm that's gonna come for like for
us for like like what climate migration
all the various threats to ice tential
life the destabilization all these
things like they're happening around us
so we have a huge responsibility to
clean up like three generations of
putting things off we have to like do a
lot like to take a burden on our backs
and we got to be able to rise up we got
to be ready for the wave has to be there
you know I mean we have to be there
ready so we need to start now trying
wicked hard to to be ready to prepare
for those challenges and that will
require immense self education among a
large proportion people it require a
cultural change that values learning and
learning and acting in the world and
trying to like do things make things
better no matter where what you are it
will require any ways of thinking about
the individuals relationship to society
and to the past into the future it
requires a lot of moral personal even
like religious change and him the way
that we then we act in the world
and so Generation Z well with the Great
American Novel I'm trying to capitalize
and get a platform right I wanna I want
to you know the New York Times with it
when Kerouac wrote on the road right the
New York Times was a big thing like this
is what the kids up to this is the Beat
Generation they love that they love to
like define new generations and I want
to use that tendency to get a foothold
to get a platform and then used to say
radically different things than what old
people are saying because I'm like young
and smart and have these things to say
and I'm studying these problems deeply
I'm diving to the wrists into the the
darkest parts of America and to the
lightest parts and want to you know show
people and teach people their own mayor
because these natives determine what we
can do and there is an air that exists
who does haven't read it they just don't
know about it because our schools were
bad and stuff they haven't tongue to
level and they haven't taught them that
great democratic inheritance that we
have you know America and in the world
but like this place is awesome
okay America is so great it's so great
it's also really [ __ ] up and been
[ __ ] up for a long
time and only by loving it so much can
you really deal with those things and
and but I believe that all the materials
we need are there we have the internet
we have the people we have the the need
we have all these ingredients we just
need these catalysts start things moving
and I want to help be that catalyst I
want to help not only like help connect
people in a Jen's II would like the way
that you do and the way that Alex does
but I also wanna inspire almost our
dialogues I want to inspire other people
to do their own crazy thing whatever
their hitchhiking on the country is do
that thing you know I mean late not
everyone's gonna hitchhike scary but but
everyone has a thing a crazy thing they
can do it I want everyone to start doing
that because we need people to do that
we need we need Hail Marys at this point
just to climate change alone and so I
want to inspire that and I want to try
to use I want you to get a platform then
leverage it in ways that can sort of
help start movements there's some
activist movements I have in mind just
for America alone like I had this whole
idea that like after college I'd love to
do like a like a new American Lyceum
there's a quick diversion but the Lyceum
movement was 1800s this was of the
religion shakakwa movement were these
self-adhesive dolt education movements
and early America its appeal like wrap
Waldo Emerson would go from town to town
to the town hall it'd be a big tide
event and he'd give his lecture and
teach them stuff and and then there's
the freedom bus rides and the sixties
all right somewhere 5060 civil rights
movement 50s I guess first the Freedom
Riders who would like willingly go to
these places to like be like hi like
segregations bad and I want combine
those ideas and basically get a bunch of
like smart kids into some school buses
which you can like mod out to live in
about half dozen people and drive around
the country and teach people about
things they have inside discussions and
have like videos of it that's a side
idea but well I'm just thinking like I
want a platform and now then I'll use it
very well I'm gonna use a platform very
well if I get it
and you mentioned water so part of this
whole Jen's do you think I'm trying to
do is idea of like a water religion so I
say social theory at Harvard it's like
my thing I was like my major technically
probably should be English looking back
on it but it's too late now
or hissed and lit but socialized is
great I love social theory I love
philosophy and one of the big sort of
things that's emerged in my study of
social theory is the a
how fundamental the like religious
impulse Emile Durkheim's elementary
forms of religious life amazing based
talks about how sociality itself village
and ours are need to like all you know
be the be a part of a tribe in our
society is that this religious forest
this collective effervescence this
connective force and how that makes us
who we are
and people like Max Weber Island in the
Frankfurt School these sort of more
depressing social theorists coming out
of movingly Germany like the late in
hundreds or nineteen hundreds they all
talk about how rationalization was like
destroying like evacuating meaning from
society right like killing religion
making things meaningless and they were
there like a big they were very afraid
of that and I there's a lot of calls for
a new kind of religion from Durkheim
also from people that monitored like
Roberto Unger a philosopher a very
interesting philosopher who's still
teaching at Harvard but about the
religion of the future you're also Emile
Durkheim and call for like a religion of
individualism so the only thing that
connects us is how I differently are you
know the way made religion and Democrat
liberalism coalesce and also Walt
Whitman and his Democratic vistas which
is like his big essay on like the
essence of democracy it's brilliant
endemic democratic vistas he he wanted
to have realized a democracy democracy
is a way deeper idea than just a
political system democracy is like a way
of life it's like oh it's a way of
conceptualizing world it's a t its
interests objective and social and full
of love and full of like and it requires
full like it's it's the mediation of the
individual decide which they this is the
problem that's gone all the way back
where I had a mediate individual in
society and democracy is like the one
that maximize that understand that the
individual needs society to grow and the
society needs the individual to like be
free and full sort of realizes sort of
liberal potential in order to contribute
back to society and democracy like
Whitman Tasha he wants to start a
religion of democracy like a Democrat a
democratic religion that's probably
basically love and sort of anyway this
calls been here for a while this does
that there's a there's a need there's a
narrative about it there's this calls
for it and I think water as the
it's like a very tangible real symbol to
project these ideas onto and use to
create a religion water religion would
would first of all be very
individualized so you don't have their
own version of it we all drink water so
it has a commonality but also we're all
made up of water raw made up of water
yes but you can protect your meetings on
to it the only sort of requirement be
like yes to be conscious every time you
drink water every time you take a shower
hear the rain or whatever just to like
actively be conscious of that water to
be like thank you water to think of the
civilization the years civilization of
pipes that brought that water to you to
think of the cycle of water from the
oceans to the rivers to the mountains
into the deer into you into the ground
into the grass into the ground again
into you to think of yourself as water
and everyone around us water to try to
see the water in them to see the same
you know blue aura and their veins that
you have so just feel connect because
religions need a connection to our
larger whole a sense of longing
that's that societal thing society God
the idea of God is basically to society
that the constant the consciousness that
would come from a larger hole that
determines us that were somehow a part
of but also subordinate to and smaller
than but also ourselves to water is that
but extends beyond our tribe to a life
so water would I think with a help deal
with global warning just warming just
Nick a sort of consciousness way it also
has rituals it's the only ritual besides
like you know breathing that we all
perform it's the only religion needs
rituals to solidify it it kind combines
like Confucianism and Daoism these two
different threads of Chinese thought in
a way it's kinda hard to explain do they
do whatever like contours Early's like
contours and the water it's kind of both
because deliver action and non-action in
water refreshes us right it's like a
reset it's like made anew its youth its
life like all their lives so
Christianity uses water for like life
right like and all the major world water
religions have some sort of water
symbolism involved some sort of water
ritual involved with the washing of the
hands or the purification of something
or a day a rain dance
you know like water is essential to
everything and given that we live in a
world where we can create meaning yes
God's dead by the gods dead and stuff
you know it happened but we can still
create meaning and it need not be a
delusion it can be based on like the
scientific perfection of h2o and this
[ __ ] God molecule the best molecule
that is so great and it's the common
denominator you know it's the common
designer it connects us to everything it
flows through us we sweat and we pee it
makes our neurons
you know allowed to be wet and and then
we get tired we expend energy we dance
we can just take a big ol you know a big
ol sip of water
Cheers thank you water mm-hmm yeah we
gotta do it anyway so it's like we might
as well you know we might as well
conscious of it and I gratitude has a
powerful effect I started noticing beige
it changed my habits
it makes me better hydrated these days
for sure I'm Way better hydrated like
than I used to be and we could do better
with not having the plastic bottles but
oh for sure for sure have refilled that
one constantly with my tuba i missin the
cap to I spilled on myself on the way
here then then it does leak the plastic
into the water so yeah so so we we can
we can we can do better but the entire
idea of being grateful for water yes
extremely important a gratitudes
powerful gratitude is very powerful for
water for the shower for so many other
times that we can see a billion of us as
water yes and this is a really good
connecting thread across generations II
that even the Millennials can get behind
and try and push up to some of the
people that are older than even us and
potentially catalyze that massive
movement to get faster to unity to
unlock more of the creative potential in
the minds make the basic physiological
needs met in people and I am I love that
unifying threat it's also it's also
something that like you said that we can
just be grateful for - it's it's a good
one it's yeah that's a great narrative
that I hope gets embedded into the Great
American Novel but also into the
movements that you inspire look we want
to get behind the Great American Novel
we want to get behind water like we love
those two things and I'm excited to
continue you know doing more of these
conversations and hopefully engaging
more people with what you're building
yeah yeah I'm glad you're I'm glad
you're on board it's a I think it's a
very powerful thing
water is the ultimate symbol it's the
ultimate symbol it's always been you
know and I just want to use that I want
to use that been there it's uh it's not
original with me I'm just I'm just just
passing through my you know
semipermeable membrane but uh I think
that water logic has profound effects in
in Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
there's this line where he looks out
from like the you know Sierra Nevada
when I wasn't looking out to the west
was California and he is Islam he's like
I can almost see the high-water mark the
high-water mark being like this in the
60s when consciousness was being raised
like where the water the floods of
change conscious like got to and then
receded you know I said cuz I've failed
the idea of the failed movement it's
also talking about Generation Z it's
like blue generations of water
generation whatever you want to call it
that you've like let the floods coming
maasai cascara duality because the
floods are also like coming in a scary
way right there's like actual floods but
also but our flood to meet it you know
will flood to meet the flood I guess and
also I guess just like in a personal
sense not only do I separate the color
balloon getting water with Association
like I I associated water I use water as
like a main mental structure for myself
it's a it's a way I conceptualize things
we even use the word contours with me
and that's a way and we're glad you
picked up on things that's like a way to
think about things see the contours
right this idea of like ruts and reality
flows through time because water's water
has always been like a simple metaphor
for time for consciousness the stream of
consciousness for for history right for
the progress of history for for flows
hitting one other of the stops and
starts the trickles that
the causality also water is so much it's
been here for billions of years and it
is just transcendent of human six
million years of civilization
constructing and evolution so just just
even that notion alone that that that we
can bond over something that transcends
us like that yes you know there's a
powerful and it bonds you know one of us
they stick together but they also have
that polarity to them you you also fill
containers they'd also expand on those
Tanner's and they can Harden to become
containers themselves so I just a think
of water as a tool for using it for
think of ideas themselves Association
itself the the use of the word contours
and ruts and old code yes another yeah
so water is like an OG code it's an
original gangster code you know it's
been there for so long they like they
won right and so if you think about it
in terms of like let's say day one being
BIGBANG sure it's not necessarily day
one but it is so far in to back before
the evolution of humans and so it's just
that thinking about old code in that
sense what is the new code updates that
we can make using metaphors analogies
that tie into the old code
that is not the banking infrastructure
but but that is water and how can that
awaken people to unity so I like I like
that a lot and where you're heading with
that I want to hit on a couple other
things on the way we have talked about
the the current era of the use of the
technological devices because they are
both so incredibly connecting and in
able to access knowledge so well
simultaneously it is causing a lot of
issues what are your thoughts especially
being 20 in the Cambridge area Harvard
said Yura are your thoughts yeah yeah my
thoughts are that are my phone is an
extension of my body you know this is a
little patch my thigh right here that's
like on a hair-trigger ready for a
vibration and that's like a part of me
you know I know when my phone's on my
right pocket and I was in the road the
same thing when I was in the road it's
like phone right pocket and then like in
pepper spray my pocket as well then and
wall in left pocket and not having it it
being over there now during our filming
I was in Connersville before cuz I was
like totally in you but now that like a
brought up like now my gosh that it's
not here and so it's extension bar but
it's extension of our social minds
primarily like I really see our minds
that are the social world as the most
important thing that's why I suppose
they're so important because we are so
much more social than we think we are
whether they the word individuals you
know we have the ego or whatever and
we're not aware we're aware our best
friends were our parents were our
sisters we're where our dad or where
we're sister exdeath dance partner you
know where the dance partner for you
these people the conglomeration of them
all and all of our thoughts because
language starts as I thought then
language is a social phenomenon that
emerge from the need to understand one
another according to Hamas then then
there are all of these important
high-level thoughts are in some way tied
to our social brain and so the the fact
that like our phone can extend our
social world harness tween howling
messenger in our pocket it is so
powerful but as you point up to me
earlier we when we were talking by phone
it's we also have and my friend Rahman
said this to me last week and he's very
rarely only have Skinner box in our
pockets we're like where we're putting
ourselves we're putting ourselves in the
clutches of everyone who wants to sell
us something repressed and the clutches
of our worst you know addiction impulses
people people at companies know about
human psychology we growing up tend to
not you know like we so and so we need
to be just aware
soon that all of these device and all
these things are trying to mold us to be
convenient for them you know they have
the site they have the psychometrics of
2 billion deploying human animals yeah
it's ridiculous the power they have and
like I I consider myself someone who me
like since I'm young you just care a lot
about like you know being a person in
psychology philosophy just having a self
like taking it very seriously like I
have I'm a person I'm a human this is
this is this wild you know this isn't
right I tell you this out but most
people don't and so if my phone gives me
that much trouble you know that can get
me to dit to Twitter and get me you know
jumping to see if some student messaging
and how much less time are we spending
on our creative actualization and so I'm
sentence oh there's like on one hand
memes broadly understood you know like
you know that Walt Whitman can be a meme
like create us and they've a pastors and
we can use them to synthesize but I
become it that becomes a point when it's
no longer a productive thing or since
that synthetic thing rather just our
reproductive like to watch the office
for the second anyone who's watched the
office more than once all the way
through should totally reevaluate their
lives like you're not growing you're not
changing you're absorbing you know
you're just it's comfort there's been
the difference between proprietary has
their they urge and urge and urge I was
the appropriate urge of the world to be
a lot of the pro Koreans out of the
world is one thing but to have recreant
comfort right to like recreate just be
comfy to listen to the song that you
know ran the new song that will
challenge you to and that having a song
stuck in your head is that power that
wants to read that wants to her laughs
do not really think too hard to like sit
back on your laurels that's a really
common thing that we that I'm very
worried about kids don't were than me
especially because like they likewise
like I I got my first phone at junior
year of high school so which I one had
his world world historically new and
significant under the hand compared to
kids five years under than me it's
wicked old and they've they also got
phones in these internet devices that
will way more developed and tailor to
them with big money big data for
for a decade whereas me using the
Internet in my public library when I was
younger like was different but also the
same but also the same you know I'm not
trying to make the binaries here it just
these nuances I guess yeah but yeah it's
powerful it's a powerful tool and also
can suck our life away so I want to use
it I wanna use it more optimally you
know and more consciously more optimally
yeah yes that's the that's the big one
is that the access to an unlimited
abundance of knowledge is so critical
finding the signal in that knowledge for
whatever one's fullest potential is is
so critical and and to be able to
consciously use the tool for that
purposes it's just so important we got
to change some of the the models that
the corporations are using to make money
off of the attention economy we've got
to change some of that and advertising
that's the new code these are the new
code deployments that have to happen
what is one thing that every child
should know going into the exponential
technology age it's the historical sense
the sense that you yeah we're throwing
to life you know we're essentially and
we're put into a narrative the mayor has
been going on for thousands of years
right there's a whole story so far
that's in your very molecules in your
bones that all of the powers and forces
and narratives that are existed are in
you and a part of you and could create
you however you also do have the power
as individual to make actions in that
story to change the story to add to it
and so I guess it's a service but
there's a kind of paradoxical taking
life seriously and not taking life too
seriously there's sort of conservation
that everyone needs to really maintain
in them I wanna take you like seriously
like wow what a blessing to live in this
world I need to learn everything about
it cuz there's so much to learn and
every Christian Furman everything but if
everyone learned something and a bunch
of things and since Isis in different
ways and becomes a unique individual
then eat with all the parts
two more you know more interactions more
syntheses more holes we just progress
and get better faster and more
wholesomely we need people we need
people to be like to have different
ghosts in them so that those different
ghosts from the past can talk near the
fact that the fact that um like shuang's
couldn't talk to Nietzsche is a it is
[ __ ] up because because they both had
similar ways of dealing with the past
like like g1 sayin Nietzsche both dug
into the history of their personal
traditions and foots of upside down and
kind of like we're radical things in
similar ways but they could never talk
in real life but in a young and in a
young girl's mind who's watching this
video I sixteen who is interested in
like freedom and like in perspectives
and in changing your way of viewing the
world really both at the same time those
two brilliant people can have a
conversation with her in her head and be
related and then as if they were living
today and could Rihanna respect risk
reactor today and that's just so
important so I think everyone needs to
self cultivate more and take their
historical position seriously the fact
that they are made of history but they
also will be making the future in a very
real sense the very like individual sets
and of course individually each
individual on one level doesn't have a
lot of value relative to the whole but I
think that way of thing but but the
little value that they do have is also
an immense great value I mean how you
zoom I think I think I think people zoom
is a little of it in the hollowness like
a we think we think that this world is
like status quo we think that we were
born into just like generic life let's
figure it out you know we're like post
the narrative ended you know when the
Nazis died you know I mean but that's
the narratives not ended we're still
doing history we're still we had to take
really seriously but also not too
serious in the sense that we can't
believe everything around us and follow
the shoes follow the sort of obvious
paths follow the narratives that are
given exactly so isn't that mixing of
taking things seriously and I -
seriously realizing the standing on the
shoulders of giants yeah hundred billion
humans before us that built civilization
tackling the biggest challenges that we
have ahead of
building the new codes the relationship
between memory and prophecy Tisa I've
been really obsessed with the Four
Quartets lately which is like TS Eliot's
like big like masterpiece of the final
four poems they're all meditations on
time and then we'll gotten a Nobel Prize
and they they're like the crown of us at
times effort and a little getting the
last one is about fire in like time and
so the end of cycle there's been one of
my favorite lines I've been like
repeating in the shower like a mantra
Lincoln spending just driving me up the
wall
it's I went into the camera - isn't he
dramatic this is the use of memory for
liberation not less of love but
expanding of love beyond desire and so
liberation from the future as well as
the past so this is the use of memory
for liberation for liberation like we
free ourselves we don't free ourselves
by living in a hollow present our
personal becomes full when we have a
president with reference to the past
hard-won taking an absorbing of the past
and by playing in relation to the future
that we expect if we expect to face
these problems or to if we want to make
a future this way we need to take the
materials we have and make it happen we
have all the materials we just don't
have them in an active sense and we need
to we need to we really desperately need
to and how about we do are we in a
simulation I'm in a simulation so that's
a great question I thought about it for
a long time I actually um I know it's
been like it talks about a lot of recent
years but I remember when I was younger
I had like a similar thought that I
detained for a while and I start
thinking about the world and one level
makes a lot of sense right like as long
as one reality gets you know far enough
to start simulating realities then most
of the realities would be the simulated
realities pretty much all of them
exactly but but there's still that needs
that one base there's still the need for
that one non-simulated
right in order stress any realities and
this I'm not caught up in everything
that people be talking about it because
I you know there might be other
positions but the way I understood it is
that like you would still require some
sort of organic you know base reality to
then simulate the rest and of course
that might be limiting the conversation
but in that sense I would say that like
why wouldn't we be there again arc
reality if it is still necessary I also
might be think about this Toni Ronis
might be an issue that only position
outside of space and time in a way that
we can't really understand we would need
to be thought about in that sense so in
that sense maybe maybe you know the
progress of reality or realities or
whatever is you know there's like a bell
curve for every possibility as the smash
goes outwards right and like in the sort
of perfect mean reality where everything
went according like maybe then that one
simulates the rest some of the
possibilities that couldn't happened and
like not retroactively lay by serving us
in sort of like a trunk
you know branches sense I guess I'm
rambling
I do do them in a simulation I think
that I think that even if we don't we
still kind of do but I think that
whatever reality could make all this
craziness happen is like a simulation
it's like you know it's it's a it's it's
ace life is pretty ridiculous life it's
pretty wild nah so and full of muchness
and whatever it is I just want to absorb
more of it and the last question is what
is the most beautiful thing in the world
oh definitely deadly people's eyes like
your eyes your pupils and your irises a
looking to people's eyes is like the
past like six Monts the most favorite
thing to do like favorite activity best
thing in the world
people's eyes on one hand right they're
all uniquely beautiful and the IRS sees
right they have like green brown blue
but all these shades of colors within
like everyone's eyes are like uniquely
different and that's like individuality
right that's like that
entity the identity with something
that's been taken in its the being that
all of your absorbed becoming so far has
like left like it's like this is you so
far it's the identity but then the pupil
is that like that yen right that subject
that like you can see that they are a
subjective being they are fully valid
like into out star you know in the pupil
in that darkness and that sort of with
all the light gets absorbed slowly the
people's eyes the most people thing ever
it commutes it communicates so much more
than words and in some senses it reminds
us that we're not I saw of cystic world
I think Descartes was a big mistake
right obvious day cards great and like
Cartesian planes are cool but soft
system was a big trap it relates to
serve all of the West's biggest problems
like imperialism and like instrumental
rationality and not understand the world
and like a other domination sort of
sense this visual culture promotional
clue and this idea that there's like
this authorizing way of being sought
isms a big mistake we're all connected
we're all deeply and interconnected
we're all you know
thus we're society with a species were
humanity more than we are individual
humans in some senses and I eyes remind
us of that and also falling in love so I
love looking into your eyes right
because like you're like an awesome
friend you're an awesome person
I love love you in a stranger's eyes too
but then looking for as if someone you
like love and you've already been in
their eyes before it combines like that
comfort in that newness is just the most
beautiful thing
some of people's eyes I love I just love
looking at people's eyes I love I love
share myself with them I know that they
can see me and I love to like release
like all my defenses to like look them
in the eye to like show them like I'm
here I'm vulnerable I'm yours and I'm on
your team and I'm on your team Alan's
course I'm on I'm on our lovely
audiences team and yeah so eyes the most
beautiful thing in the world
grateful to my sight that was very
eloquently described yeah I love eyes as
well I'm really happy that that was the
beautiful thing in the world for you
thank you yeah there's so much to unpack
still about our conversation and in all
of its a nuance there was so much good
stuff that we discussed oh yeah yeah you
rocked it Aidan
Thank You Alan yeah and I love you very
much I love me too I love what you're
building
I appreciate that yeah we're gonna rock
it together we're gonna keep growing
hell yeah together yeah leveling up and
building co-creating this is line it's
like he wasn't put to a hill before dawn
he looks like the starry the the full
packed heavens of stars and he's like
and this is like and my spirit said when
we become the in folders of those orbs
and of the pleasure and knowledge of
everything within them will we be full
and content then and then and then I
answered no we will then lift and level
to the next level to it to absorb more
there's always a get greater there's
always there's always more that Emerson
is actually called circles as always you
can always draw a larger circle on each
circle that's a very essential piece of
American thought is the idea of constant
change concentrated segments constant
experimentation constant encapsulating
of a larger whole yeah but let's decide
one more thing or thing this another
women lying where he goes now understand
me well it is provided in the essence of
in the essence of things that from any
fruition of success from any fruition of
success no matter what shall come forth
something to make a greater struggle
necessary it's so good it's just the
amount of synthesizing that you've been
doing across the greatest thinkers and
poets and novelists it's just been
outstanding and it's so evident in the
that you speak about history and the way
that you speak about solving and
tackling the challenges with things like
a Great American Novel as well as even
the water as such a binding they get for
us and I'm really grateful for you and
I'm grateful for our ability to have an
audience that has cared about that
pisode what we talked about everyone I
urge you I urge you thank you so much
for tuning in thank you thank you thank
you give us your thoughts in the
comments below in the episode I urge you
to check out the Great American Novel
check out what Aiden's work is do what
he's doing check out the links and the
bio to that have more conversations
around you about the subjects that we
talked about your friends your family or
coworkers people on the Internet
just get conversing more about some of
these great American ideas as well as
about how we can put the new codes and
that can tackle some of these greatest
challenges and support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below so you
continue doing cool things like
hopefully by 2020 building out the
recording studio in Cambridge our second
one in addition to the one in San
Francisco and also go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
nice good job thank you good job that
was so fire awesome but yeah you rocked
it